(gentle music)
♪ Time passes quickly here ♪
♪ Everything new ♪
♪ Childhood behind us now ♪
♪ Fading from view ♪
♪ Four years stretch out before you ♪
♪ Hope rushing in ♪
♪ Just breathe in and close your eyes ♪
♪ Time to begin ♪
♪ Raise your voices here for an evening ♪
♪ Raise your voices with me for a time ♪
♪ Raise your voices and in the weaving ♪
♪ Yours will lift the sound of mine ♪
♪ Time passes quickly still ♪
♪ Life richly drawn ♪
♪ Wisdom of lessons learned ♪
♪ Youth nearly gone ♪
♪ Our bright college years
endure as memories within ♪
♪ But always the song rings out ♪
♪ Once more begin ♪
♪ Raise your voices here for an evening ♪
♪ Raise your voices with me for a time ♪
♪ Raise your voices and in the weaving ♪
♪ Yours will lift the sound of mine ♪
♪ Raise your voices here for an evening ♪
♪ Raise your voices with me for a time ♪
♪ Raise your voices and in the weaving ♪
♪ Yours will lift the sound of mine ♪
♪ The sound of mine ♪
(bird chirping)